what's up F podcast Colin show
323 282 7424 call in 30 minutes don't
call right now no one going to pick up
that phone with Rodrigo Torres yeah man
and special guest just got back from
touring the Europe and brought a chick
from the UK like a
sa give it up for S kin from min right
here to pick up too yeah man what's
happening what's happening one and only
that fool's back looking for the last
Pioneer Chicken to be
open remember that dog all right two
years ago dog shout outs
to right there Tom from San Antonio solo
e377 JJ 775 Frankie AED Arad Frankie
Ahad when Butler last night
big puppy golf one onone Cali gutters
oneon-one cell gut I guess they got a
plumber Tero California this week
October 7th to the 9 every show is sold
out there might be some tickets left
over for Sunday second show at 9:00 on
Sunday plus also man they might open up
some extra tickets I don't know man you
go find out scalpers October 7th through
9th all right man for this show always
sold out man if you waited till the last
minut man don't don't come to my page
and email me that my credit card didn't
work at the time I don't have a credit
card ma [__] in my house I can't
validate nothing like that PayPal also
man if you bought like seven tickets and
now you need four more tickets and
they're sold out I can't do nothing
about that came up short hey man I just
want to say thank you for getting those
seven tickets and thank you for the
people that are smart enough now to know
that when you when whenever I come to
California you got to buy the ticket six
months ahead of time yeah man at least
at least a month people don't wait for
the last minute man these they start out
pretty effective people they want to go
to the show man they got plans too
showed up to the box office talking
about it's sold
out do they hit you up do they hit you
up too like the show if it's sold out
not only that man forget about it if the
show is sold out I can't even walk over
there and say hello to people cuz Hey
man I'm I into the podc can you give me
in the front of the line yeah you get
mobed yeah I know can you give me in the
front of the line
man you got the hook
up come on S I knew you us to SP your
name with a k
bro still don't up
anything us to see at the yeah no they
sell they start telling people their
distant relatives and like all kinds of
[__] how many people you have that say
you're you're their family how you know
how many people hang up look at my
emails when they when I send them back
they
go
he he's all
Hollywood he went Hollywood somebody
said that when we were filming the
special in San Jose they wrote a long
letter bro about what what happened how
I went through my joke real fast in the
second show and didn't no this was the
first show the first show how I how when
I did an hour that I went through my Jew
real fast and didn't go outside to meet
and greet after the first show after the
first show it was crazy and we flew from
Milwaukee no the Kansas we flew from
Milwaukee Dorothy we flew from Milwaukee
I'm just milking Milwaukee up but they
didn't really F from Milwaukee what's
called it flew from the W the L with
through the
B anyways what else did they say Lisa
they said that um it's not like you fast
forward the show you have to be present
and wait be in the moment tile was I'm
disappointed I'm disappointed and how
are you going to make it up for us give
him a little meal you didn't I'm going
say cho the do five
minutes CH you have to fast that far
we're right here talking
[__] Jesus if you're listening
[__] we're talking [__] right
now
Jesus
Jesus oh my god dude you're killing me
right now shout out to um R Mambo 20th
anniversary oh hell yeah you guys went
there last weeko Manny to the max was
there bro he he took a Rin he wasn't
that
excited Ronaldo was there also was there
DJ coo bro I got to see the top of his
body people take their photos from you
know oh yeah like chick style some fat
ass from Fresno forgot his name
um that F was sweating dog F they had
buffet brunch oh yeah brunch free beer
man oh [__] coo had a cold one already
bro damn I was Triple another that was
drinking early but then again I was
drinking early too
back in the days should have
judge was there pops was there bro
looking for somebody to choke hey bro M
was there what's up 60 years old that
[__] he looks good huh dude 60
years old I was there when that food
turned
40 damn I remember that whole week I
never forget that whole week we were in
Houston bro the Texas Houston Texas just
played the first game that day so I show
empty and G Ro headlining real [__]
empty bro and then um we to go go score
some but some weed and um damn bro that
F brought us back swag dog so you don't
smoke weed out you don't care no but but
I collect a lot of it all right yeah
every gig man I when we just did Denver
like a couple of weeks ago we did this
huge Festival in Denver and uh I went
out into the crowd to talk to some
friends and I got mobbed and my pockets
were full of joints and like these like
uh Vape uh but I guess they have weed or
something oh yeah man dude my pockets
were full dude so like I went backstage
and my our road crew loves me CU I just
I just distribute all that [__] to I
would yeah I'll be shaking his hand
frisking him bro hell yeah dude also man
Arlington Virginia DC area October 14
and 15 at Arlington Draft House San
Diego California October 21st for one
night only at humph by the bay if you
don't have ticket for that show man you
could Pat a boat to that show and stand
there watch it all night just get a
jacket man anybody p a b to that show
man I'm might have a shroom I feel like
getting um shrooms feel like getting um
shms bro and get one of those shotgun
shirt sh shirt blasters to [__] shoot
a gun to one of those boats you us some
merch
bro how they going to say send us a 20
bucks though for the shirt I don't
that's right H pass the wire homie pass
the
wire Salt Lake City man Utah at Wise
Guys Comedy Club get up the show is
going there all shows can be found at
philip.com
tour also man we had an awesome weekend
last week man we were [__] hanging out
with Mike hers what's up man man what's
up F tell him bro happen I tell him I
ABC who the clamp fool dud he's all
right when we walk up to this fo what's
up man I need some
weed I was like damn all right cool that
walked away with walked away with it
like shorty bro yeah we roll This fat
blunt right and then that fool grabs it
we oh he'll light it up dog this F
didn't let it go for like 15 minutes and
then this fo's looking at me God damn
dog was we gave that for little Neil dog
and he passed by us yeah we like uh yeah
dog it's for you but not for you for
you pass it already he clamped that [__]
like a vice cre I know man I thought I
thought I thought um we were handing him
about Tom bro part of a relay
race you said next time you're going to
put some fishy streak on there with a
little fish his stre on that blood give
me that [__] back n man he was cool
though oh cool as hell man fipe we need
to do a movie together oh man as soon as
Mike F saw me he gave me a big hug we
should do a movie together I said we
should bro off my in Mexico I'll play
leardo live off the fat of the land so
what saw see how was the tour that was
killer man Europe was uh was amazing we
were out there for like a month and uh
yeah it was uh it was uh off the hook
this time around new uh new band members
we have a new drummer and a new base
player and you know it's been killer so
yeah you guys stay in a lot of hotels
yeah a lot man we've been stay a lot of
hotels but lately like we were in um
where were we at we we at the show in
Fresno there was no hotels in Fresno
right because they were having a a thing
called a slum Fest there a bunch of
bikers showed up and B Bubba spark was
performing um yellow wolf yellow wolf a
lot of bands I never heard of and um and
and and and one of our our friends um
Jerry from bud glos man the drummer he
was performing was this um was his um
Japanese guy he's called um ukulele hero
ukulele hero and he plays ukuleles and
he plays punk rounds let me go yeah he
doesn't but like a twister in the
sun really it's a ukulele and the horn
Parts is with the kazoo yeah and then
the like a one Manon band yeah and our
friend plays drums [__] oh cool but
Jerry's so crazy man because he's a
party animal he looks like Curly from
The three stos bro if curly would start
now or back then now today today bro how
he would look now like he like he looks
like some like his body a man it looks
like he they stuffed a turtle shell it's
like he's solid though solid handshake
real nice guy but he's funny man cuz
like he thinks like I think like like no
matter where you're at he'll he'll find
a way to party and still get away with
doing his job yeah yeah cuz yeah man Ian
I I just have a kick drum you know and
play Bongo sh I get [__] up and play
all
night he figured it out he figured it
out he could have do that before he
couldn't do that before man broke your
fingers you
know play with his getting drum sticks
so where'd you stay at if there was no
Hotel Fowler wasel called Fowler bro let
me tell you man Fowler not the place to
travel with your girlfriend whatever
that she needs she ain't going to find
there oh oh what up I forgot my curly
KNE let's go buy went a CVS sorry honey
that [__] place FL at 1:00 p.m.
wasn't that crazy got there at 109 dude
they locked the doors on us we got there
at 1:30 that CVS closed at 100
p.m. yeah I need to avoid that place
what is it Fowler Fowler California man
it's small bro they they vote there by
phone what's up you want to vote forone
yeah and it's funny there's three people
running in that town an Armenian guy a
mexic and a white guy so it's pretty
tight all running from each other
right let you get political over here
but when we're driving over there a lot
of the Farms they had um Trump and Pen
signs Trump and Pen signs which didn't
make any sense because you guys hire
illegals all the time I know huh very
conservative this F has nothing but
illegals working there and you have a
trump pen sign yeah man just like Trump
don't pay I understand his feeling you
know you know because as a if as a
businessman if I'm hiring illegals to
work for my land and I'm paying them a
little bit I also want a tax break oh
yeah maximize
your but think about it you know that's
that's genius if you're thinking that
way oh hell yeah you no economically you
economically he wants to pay less taxes
and still hire cheap labor make more
money do make more money do [__]
American Dream
bro make American shout out to the devil
man for always making us laugh with
Instagram post give me a
spot there's a guy right there with an
Instagram and this kid doesn't follow
nobody back I know what's up it's cool
like that what makes him a legend I know
huh CU every once in a while he'll chime
in good little child do this a guy that
we call the devil yeah and U he always
calls in he puts in the right word like
at the right time at the right time of
Instagram oh man I wish like when we put
the photo up of the three of us the col
in Show he goes oh man nobody picked up
my
call so he's funny like that man he
knows all the lingo and all the stuff
from podcast since day
one a parody account a very good parody
by the way ah a very good parody cuz the
guy the parot knows if you're into the
inside joke it's hilarious dude so
what's your best coner youever been to
Bro three minutes ah dude for ranted in
1995 in um in India California at rock
and blues dude I still have visions of
that show dude they just ripped it dog
it's before they blew up and they
[__] kicked ass everything was
perfect just sounded as good as a
[__] record live yeah yeah dude so
that's what's it was a small place the
sound guy who made it possible or the
whole venue them the venue and the
talent too cuz I mean you can have yeah
and if you ain't talented it's not going
to [__] come through an experience if
you walked into the [__] gig an ass
piss up the sound guy right immediately
you're going to have a [__] up show
off you can [__] up your show yeah and
at that time they weren't even carrying
the sound guy all they had was a mer Pro
of oh hell yeah cuz do you guys roll
with your own sound guy we do oh yeah
there you go those guys D like divas bro
yeah fo I saw a sound guy one time in an
airplane and you know I said you and I I
think we saw him he was wearing one
backpack oh yeah he had a sound gear
there old man he was doing um this big
ass concert oh yeah had 10 CH 10
hipsters following
him his little crew best concert you
been to uh kiss
1978 damn yeah and it was actually it
was a mini concert it was when they were
filming kiss me to The Phantom of the
park over at Magic Mountain like I got I
got tickets for that and there was a
scene in there where they um they let
like 500 uh parking passes and I won one
of those parking passes and uh me and my
cousins went and they did like uh they
probably did like 10 songs but it was
the original four guys you know in 78 so
yeah yeah dude was it was you know Peter
Ace Jean and Paul saw free concert yeah
oh dude I saw that movie man and then
when I I started watching it again I was
like e why dude it's horrendous but but
that's what makes it great cuz it's
little kid that's your favorite band as
a little kid was badass bro cuz I always
wanted I never grew out of that I always
want to be bro look at that oh man still
represent dude Dan love do you have a
wristband are you listening yeah a did
you meet Danny you didn't meet Danny
love right no he's a he's a he's a Cho
right from
Texas no the Midwest yeah Kansas yeah he
he's from Garden City Kansas we had
Danny love I met him cuz Lisa and I
we're going to the movie theaters we're
coming out of about thing Dell Taco or
Taco Bell right there we're going to the
media center 6 and we saw this little
dude little dude this dude passed by
with long hair and I was wearing my Kiss
shirt from Dodger Stadium he was cool
shirt man he goes thank you man he goes
man man you like Paul Stanley yeah man I
do Paul Stanley and a kiss Co over
bad so [__] so we hit it off right there
we we started talking for like 10 I did
did my 10 Minute Podcast right there
with him I never saw him again but then
I ran into him at a burger joint and I
said bro I have a podcast you want to do
it this guy has and we went to his house
to do it fool this guy has mad mad kiss
collection really huge you have one to
oh yeah big time dude we got to get
Danny love and S next time bro and
[__] have a kiss remember me yeah
we'll out kiss each
other and that's the thing isz like
being a kiss f is like a hardcore thing
dny love what he said man once he meets
a kiss a kiss collectible guy they could
talk for two hours yeah dude and you us
you size each other up dude and you're
like oh yeah you got this i got this and
like that's how it get then they P the
tongue out bro it's over yeah exactly
dude yeah then we start using it then
it's really
over cu Lopez is a big George Lopez also
a big yeah another kid fan yeah but I
don't think George Lopez has a lot of
stuff bro I'm just
saying coolu like the guitar he has the
guitar but I would like people to show
me like stuff that everybody could get
like the baseball cards well they had a
lot of lunch boxes and [__] all types of
[__] sleeping bags dude I got they have
coffins yeah cofin a coffin question
refrigerator that's what I sleep in the
the kiss cars that you have are those
the ones that that came in looking like
an record album you can eat it uh
no you remember those Bubblegum the
bubble the bubblegum one yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh you got that yeah well I
don't have anymore bad ass you don't
remember those theum kiss yeah dud my
mom had a kiss record I was Kiss The
Beetles maybe The BJs and they they had
like a little baseball cards but like
the monkeys too the monkeys right but
some of them were you will open it up
and it'll have like a gum and it was
shaped like a record it was like a
record but it was are you serious that's
badass kind like Tops baseball cards
came with a gum yeah yeah that's cool
dude I came my little Coke powder inside
yeah well it didn't stick a dude when I
went to um I did an episode of uh Jean
Simmons Family Jewels years ago like his
first season and um I went to his house
I went to his house and and he dude his
office is kiss Museum right oh dude I
was like freaking out there I was just
peeing myself dude just standing there
seeing all the stuff the prototypes that
he had that like [__] that never came
out it was just it's unbelievable bunch
of Japanese [__] too yeah all kinds of
stuff dude yeah all kinds of Japanese
people were there yeah it was crazy [__]
yeah my concert pool I think is cuz it
was also free ah this one full I was in
I was in Las Vegas cheerleading bro and
um that and Willie Bara had just got
thrown out of the comedy club for
fighting with somebody what he think
look that bro big mistake bro he was
fighting for Ernie G's to stay
oh see fo and they both got kicked out
good so big dog and Ernie G had no gig
on New Year's Day oh wow so I was there
to watch them perform right and they had
Dam hanging out Willie had Ernie G
blowing up balloons on theity on the on
the on the [__] um Pioneer or the
state level whatever that street
is
Freemont bro blowing up B blowing up
balloons and making art for people for
money for will to start drinking more
drinking more God damn they have more
party drinking money right so [__] they
were just [__] whatever right the
first party started they Ernie G stop it
bro cuz they no license oh they come
down on his ass yeah
so I think of will um lady shows up and
um so we're there now with nothing to do
this foood just buys [__] who's go
let's go see George Carlin bro so he
buys five tickets and we all go see
George Carlin and we're in the front
shut up and George car wearing black
pants black jeans and then like you see
bro I wear black jeans and black pants
and he's up there with his notes he has
a he has a a manila folder uhhuh a
manila notebook the college the college
brand he does his hour of old material
like whatever um then he goes to his new
all right people now for the serious
stuff he goes through his um HBO special
it goes like 35 minutes and he goes to
the next page and he's thinking about it
he's pondering he goes um George calling
go all right we got time for fart jokes
you got want some fart jokes he's like
for the [__] 10 minutes of fart jokes
bro are you serious wow yeah bro and I
did them
already that's some funny on man you
ever like make a fart and then the chair
you move the chair and it makes a fart
and you get the chair do the same fart
no they won't do
it you know stuff like that you fart and
the fart follows
you but a bunch of ones dude and um I
was enlightened bro I was like you know
man I felt like I'm not there you know
really not there outside of it outside
of it watching it you know I felt like I
am not where he's at you know cuz he was
comfortable he was like man 70 years old
still and I F like [__] I want to get
you that comfortable where I could just
whip out my note list and go to work and
still make them laugh I thought that was
probably my best concert bro really dude
I didn't even knew you seen George
Carlin fo we saw that full close bro but
you know if you guys see um Willie barel
tell man hey thank you for taking me to
George Carlin bro bad to get get kicked
out of that club it's a good bad thing
and a good thing talking in it was that
so um Carlos Oscar ended up featuring
now on that show cuz Carlos Oscar shout
out to Carlos Oscar if you're listening
you know what really went down yeah bro
Char carar was his wife and two kids bro
damn back then they're little little
then huh they had little little Le
jacket like little Puerto
Rican I want about about car Oscar he
keeps it real bro little PTO Ric the
jackets bro they were like walking
around bro like you know checking for
and they had little go
chains keep it in me Puerto Rican dog
Yeah man so he featuring Jeff Jenna damn
he ended up headlining you're lying yes
dude he used to run the um Irvine Improv
back in the day the Jenna was featuring
and he got bumped up really dog oh dude
cuz that big old Scandal between big dog
and uh what did stupid ass Ori do fool I
don't know man oh he keep giving that F
guest spot probably I don't
know but if they tell me to give
somebody a gift but I'm not going to
cancel the whole show [__] we're both
going to lose and we're both never going
to come back hey dog you have to wait in
the car dog so that's why that fool he
had that fool blowing up balloons out
the rest of the day to make money he
[__] up for he went to bat for him so
the fo was drinking free off the club
bro that might be my next gig dude if
this ministry ban thing doesn't work out
I might he doing balloons over on
Fremont Street too dude Jesus what about
what was your what was your first like
band concert oh man Beasty Boys at Run
DMC that was your first or the best the
best [__] man the worst Kake the cake
man I don't know man I seen probably
when I went to the krock Weenie Roast
that was badass and I saw um Everybody
bro all at once white zombie
fente um goingo
Boingo Beck wow um Offspring oh
damn next week oh okay what we're
playing with off spring next week
they're doing that Festival got keep
them separated oh the not Fest yeah yeah
[__] yeah I remember those weenie R
those were good shows man on my birthday
bro June 11
1998 it was damn dude and I ran to the
car right and I bought a [__] ticket
for my friend Rafa Moran if you're
listening Raul Vasquez you know what I'm
talking about you're listening I bought
a ticket for that food to go at the last
minute on the day of the gig that fol
couldn't go f [__] that dog so I took my
loser brother oh that F got lucky dog no
I took my he's not a loser he's cool I
took my I took my little brother Albert
bro and that F was in high school dog a
dude he was into all those bads [__]
listen to krock at the time and I called
him up I said hey bro you want to go to
a [__] concert right now the krock
Weenie Roast I got [__] Orchestra
seeds at the Irvine Meadows he goes hell
yeah and I picked that fo up bro we ate
Del Taco over there there ate a lot of
food dropped that food off did you get
nachos nachos dog I had a [__]
chicken burrito supreme man that was a
best burrito ever bro spicy chicken oh
man I'm vegan now but I can still talk
about
it white chicken with cheese sour cream
no beans man wow exactly hit the spot
dude yeah man he just had did you real
he just had like a like a Vietnam
flashback just
flavor they had a grab bag to win prizes
and I put my hand in and I stuck out a
Green Day OD album my first CD Wow God
damn no I'm sorry um dookie oh dookie
yeah man but I thought when I be was
awesome on that concert he had that
album also the the The Cannonball was
there what the guy The Cannonball who oh
they're they sing um no that girl that
girl from that from friends is in that
video
I'm stumped right now the the guy has
curly ass hair C
Crow give him a priz over there yeah
afan wigs was there too Afghan wigs dude
yeah man there's a lot of good bands I
saw that 98 dude who who headlined that
show um Counting Crows bro really cuz
they were big back then too that's was
in that show oh dude that's when Green
Day was all green day went up before
cting crows bro that fo took his pants
off oh yeah yeah no probably yeah yeah
dude sounds like
touring you know KISS played one of
those weenie Rose like in
96 I think I saw kid at Dodger Stadium
3D bro I was there too dude still have
the glasses I working hot dogs bro is
that you got the shirt I might have
bought some from you dude probably did
bro I got to see the three tenders too
oh they poti Jose
caringo yeah damn I was there bro it was
weird bro how was that [__] dude Sur
Real selling
champagne damn and CH and chocolate
cover chocolates and we were selling all
kind of stuff that we normally wouldn't
sell but people were buying it the merch
I went over there bro got me a merch and
I got me a [__] the three ters on top
of Dodger Stadium you still have that
shirt [__] no oh no that's a badass
shirt threw that [__]
went I
wish one of the best shirts to have
though of Dodger Stadium is Jackson 5
of them are on top of dodg Stadium like
this with Michael Jackson in the middle
that's a badass shirt wow that has to
exist somewhere dog also Metallica too
when they played theak when they played
Oakland they were wearing Raider jerseys
oh okay [__] yeah the Raider fans speak
of Metallica bro I listen to radio
earlier and they go into uh they were
talking about getting a a finger up your
butt and get what was that prostate exam
uhhuh they go to prostate exam then
after that they go
into the forgiven bro I just think about
the old man why he's
suffering he's getting a prostate exam
damn do man that was the idea we're
going to ask these fools what their
[__] favorite concert was and they
got a two menes to say it or their worst
cool time it
it what's up
fool what's up fool what's up for who's
this this is Sergio from Greenville
South Carolina where I what's up
bro how you doing out there
partner good man when you got to come
out here I don't know man hopefully I
get to hopefully I get booked at Raleigh
or
something Raleigh that's four hours away
the closest to the beat
dog fire R the engine hey bro what's
your what was your best concert or worst
concert you've been to so um best
concert I'm originally from California
and uh my favorite band system of it
down I saw them in 4 at the Greek
Theater Rodrigo must have been there I
didn't go to that show I just seen him
recently at the for though dog
yeah April 15th or 8th or something like
that how many are meia with that concert
bro oh dude the hairs were coming out of
the chest shirts were un button the
Bro Glendo there white iPhones iPhones
with the gold the gold trim was there
Ming at that show yeah you know the
Greek Theater has that small pit in the
front in the front yeah totally and
that's why that's why it was so nice
because the pit was really small and the
sound was really good so it was uh it
was [__] crazy man that was cool how
what your worst
concert worst
concert um it was a few years ago
remember when uh ly biscuit tried to
come
back Meadow this said
tried key word
tried fast they played at Irvine medals
it was like this uh bring back the 90s
[__] I forget what it was called but
that
was it was whacked in or what yeah it
was pretty
whack hell yeah what's up Greenville
North
Carolina South Carolina South Carolina
say hello to Pablo Pete bro hell yeah
dog thanks for calling bro hey love the
podcast man thank you thank you brother
hell yeah that was
tight what's up
fool what's up fool we got s Karin from
ministry here with us bro I heard man
what's up dog what's your favorite
concert you ever been to best one who is
he who are you bro yeah by the way this
is Rick man from uh from Florida what's
up Rick Florida hey this this is my
homie right Rick that gave me those
tickets to Mega con
right n man all right man yeah Best
Concert dog who the best concert you
ever been to bro
man I've been to a lot of P you know
concerts so let him know which one bro
the best one
Commander yeah no not
even Ramon
yala no not even man but the last one I
went to was Mana my old lady oh Latino
Power Tour
dog yeah it was actually the drama loose
they had yeah that's the best one have a
badass drum where did you see it at
Orlando Orlando big place yeah at the
arena there at the uh where they have
the [__] Magic Place damn sold out
huh it was tight man a lot of females
though man sh thought you went with your
lady tell I my lady but you know I gotta
PE an
eye
man hell yeah give a real little spy eye
Bic give little check out that girl's
ass
huh [__] RoboCop eye
dog yeah too bad it was too dark
couldn't put any Shades but you know I
gotta next time what's your worst
concert
fool the
worst see way or the worst concert ju
Gabrielle or what n man
uh let's say
uh I think it was one of the Bic ones
man we got into a rumble a rumo huh yeah
or what shocking rud you you put rud or
n man um yeah I think it was uh was hes
oh
damn wow wow goodness man we're in eore
City there's a club out
there and uh yeah man we just got into a
little Rumble I was actually underage at
the time man [__] and one of the [__]
bouncers caught me drinking right I
dring Corona and [__] yanked the
coron at my hand and then my P homeboy
just
clock that [__]
boom
right yeah so they end up uh yeah they
end up kicking us out but the thing is
man we the guy I knew knew the guy who
from the hakan that's how we got in and
one of the Young Dudes I guess one of
the sons who plays the
accordion but uh that end up going
outside going to the tour bus bus out
the accordion and we're just he just
playing outside man well we're just
chilling out there after we got kicked
out ni damn you got the Royal treatment
for red carpet and all it was tight as
[__] I mean I you know my homeboy still
got the picture been years ago man hell
yeah man I've been to eort City before
bro next time I'm in ebore City you
should go I perform as a Tampa Improv
yeah man I always go to your shows I've
went to the last two you know when you
had Rodrigo win and then uh keep Manning
the last one how yeah man get off the
field get off the field fol thanks for
calling man hell yeah bro man keep it up
peace dog
oh you hear [__] Ramon not not um
Mario M died today yeah man Mexican
Charles
Bronson yeah's going down man yeah man
hello what's up fool who's this what's
up fool what's up fool who's this this
is the homie flip from Escondido what's
up homie flip from ESO you're here with
Rodrigo Tori and sin from
Ministry what's what's up homies what up
chilling fool
hey bro what's your best what's the your
best concert you ever been to like when
you said man it's a badass
concert the best concert i' ever been to
it was a I went to a rayate concert
right here at the the local fair but I
ain't never been to no big concert how
was it man like best band you ever seen
live best band you seen
live it was uh I believe the guy was eam
Mouse oh [__] yeah he's bad dude he had
a he had a [__] cowboy hat on I think
a r gave with the cowboy hat
R I think his name is hey dog I'm gonna
be down there in [__] Humphrey hell
yeah bro you're gonna p a boo it or what
[__] you know how we do it it's F dog F
to be the in Tu
bro with the in Tu I wouldn't be
surprised bro yeah see how many
ingenious fools there is that night dog
that' be funny man you see somebody with
what happened bro I show up in a
submarine
bro scuba gear dog scuba
steve what's the worst concert you been
to
dog bro what's the worst concert you
been
to it's gon to have two inner tubes at
will call I tell the worst concert but I
can tell you the worst car show I've
been
to park
hell yeah hell yeah hey you guys uh you
guys GNA be staying down there or what
yeah bro we're gonna be staying in isono
yeah at the Quality yeah you guys want
you don't want to stay in esono homie
hell no bro I want to stay there to you
the
restroom
IAH off a National Boulevard you know
what's more ghetto bro elone or
esono I say Esco more ghetto yeah damn
CH [__] we love it
though representing right I love my
dollar Chinese
restaurant I do laundry next door dog in
the front that's funny you know you know
you grew up in Escondido if you do
laundry Chinese food and check cashing
in the same Corner got to run my
a if you buy Chinese food and donuts at
the same dut shop you live in thiso it's
an
efficient hell yeah hey do I was
checking out your [__] uh Netflix
special last night oh yeah thank you man
that [__] was [__] hilarious dog
that's the first time I ever seen you
like on the standup I just heard you
through the podcast through Joe Rogan
Uncle Joey and all them oh thank you man
and I started listening through that but
uh yeah dog that was the first time I
ever heard you that [__] was [__]
sick dog I can't wait till uh go see you
live hell thank you
man there you going to be down there
Rodrigo is he yeah no Marcel's be there
he's gonna do do doing standup or
what rrio will be there bro in spirit
yeah man hell yeah we're gonna make a
hologram with
him I'm gonna stock you rles down so we
can blaze up all right
bro bring the
lancha I'll be out there on the Water
Dog with the [__] light flashy the
flare Navy SEAL over here dog we're
going to make a [__] Lighthouse
bro that be the drop off Giggles over
here dog F show a rbo
dog battle boat and a lamp have you seen
Pinocchio all right bro thanks for
calling man from all the way from esono
California all right G take care [__]
yeah
late this F always gets through though
oh was
yeah hello hello how you hello how you
doing who's this who's this what's up PO
this is Amalia Morales de Mo home girl
what's up what's happening all the way
from De Mo Iowa how you
been yes I'm good how are you guys hi
Rodrigo hi
sink we're good man we're just here
hanging having a good
yeah asking people what their favorite
concert was or dude so so many concerts
it's not even funny um yeah I'm so so
glad I got to call you um don't know if
you remember but like I told you last
time I talked to you I pretty much
talked to you like Periscope
Facebook um and then I told you on
Periscope I was like oh yeah I'm gonna
try and call cuz I I'm always working
and stuff and here I am on a lunch break
I'm like man I have to get through I
have to call have to say hi I have to
make some time so I'm so happy I'm able
to call and and just say hi and what's
up again um yeah so so just want to say
you know keep doing what you're doing
with the the podcast and everything and
um I heard you on Kevin and Dean
recently that was cool that was
fun hell yeah thanks for
listening you heard it all the way Mo on
the Internet or
what no um oh yeah you mean Kevin and
Bean yeah yeah yeah um I download the
the podcast like same way I listen to
yours um so I just I hear their show
every day and um you know I saw that you
were G to be on I'm like oh [__] yeah so
I checked it out and and it was cool I
mean I wish they would have had you on
longer but still me
too yeah how's the weather in De Mo
getting cold
huh getting cold out here it's I mean
gradually it's um it's actually really
nice still like October September
October is still really nice um but then
we start freezing our asses off around
Thanksgiving bacon de Mo time huh you
got to check me out next week on the
show Superstore on NBC I'll come out at
9:00 October 13th oh next next week
already oh hell yeah hell yeah for sure
everybody listening October 13 NBC 9:00
I make my acting debut
awesome on a television show that be TI
it's gonna be you know what that means
one more year of of dental and medical
insurance
sag well thanks for calling
Amia yeah hell yeah I love you guys you
know just love you just always what's up
we love you too right back at
you yeah thank you and I I just want to
say to um you know when you had Destiny
bar uh co-hosting like we always miss
Rodrigo you know Miss that laugh
everything but Destiny V was funny he
was a cool guy and I mean seriously you
guys killed me when you guys with the
what you want fed us oh my God
ridiculous like killed me it was that's
gonna be a restaurant we're going to
Dustin bar and I we got a television
deal with ABC so we're going to they're
going to write a pilot and hopefully
it'll be on television ABC so Dustin iar
and I will play Brothers in a
show I'm going to I'm going to watch
that too hell yeah hell yeah and I I
emailed our local Funny Bone and they
have not gotten back to me because we
need you out here in the mid so now you
send two more emails the neighbor send
and have 10 friends send emails every
week they I'm G start harassing and [__]
because they they just did not get back
to me and there is hardly any Latino
representation and it's getting annoying
so I'm gonna start bugging some people
start right now yes start
pick yeah thank you for do
that all right guys thank you thank you
always keep up the good work much love
to Lisa C love it yes we need another
episode what's up fool have a good
one hello hello hello hello hello hi oh
my gosh oh my gosh do I get to talk to s
yes he right here how you doing hello oh
my God oh my God oh my God hey s hello
who's this hi how you doing this isy who
Betsy Betsy
Betsy
hello hello it's gone she's gone she's
gone somebody's hung
up she got all excited husband gra the
phone yeah had to
go you stalking that guitar player again
what's up
dog what's
up who's this
fool oh what up
dude
who I can't hear you what was
that it's Victor from Eagle oh what up
dog up man other way from Eagle Rock bro
you sound like you were trapped in a um
in a trunk or something what's happening
Jack crossing the border
hell yeah fool what's your favorite
concert you've been to the best one the
best one I've been to K
Frost I like 10 years ago I went to see
first only concert I got my nose broken
at at the hive concert the hives a bunch
of white guys wow the hives huh wow they
were mushing at the hives conert that's
crazy that little white suits and little
black eyes yeah yeah they must have poin
in at you or something going a look for
some uh some targets that night had to
be you're probably the only Mexican
there he got the
MS what up real quick hell yeah dog
what's up Victor man don't forget to P
call every show hell yeah man you got in
bro rock you got in bro too bad we're
not giving away prizes the bonus round F
what's the worst concert you've been to
dog what's the worst concert that was
Ito that's the only one his nose broken
bro so that's not the best
one the only one wow well don't lose
hope you can still come see
Ministry you go Ministry bro that'll be
the
worst the
best you probably get your nose broken
to that one too I'll probably fix it bro
yeah
exactly it's all good now I'm just
trying to say what's up guys you know
see how you guys doing this month and
[__] you what's up fool hell yeah dog
that's all it is it hell yeah but uh
take care guys I'm just calling to get
in and that's it you know hell yeah bro
getting harder and harder that's what
she said hell yeah hey now hey now not
to Rodrigo right yeah hell yeah dog all
right do I'll talk to you later be cool
man keep shining
F what's up
fool what's up fool
hello hey what's up up F this is uh
Lorenzo Cruz calling I'm at work right
now I just want to to call and say
what's up you're talking that you're
about to go kill everybody right
now he at the post hey man this is it
I'm about to just [__] just take my
life right
nowo you sound like somebody about to
walk out of work early bro all calm hey
actually I'm trying to get out early
today collect there you go you're
working on your boys offer here at the
supply room anybody want pens he sounds
like we're about to watch him on the
news later I know
right we talked to that F dog right
before he did
it what's up man what's your best cure
you've been to fol he blow up he stick a
dynamite or
something what's up bro you sneaking
around work
for hey I work at a casino so I'm over
here in the corner hiding out s well hey
nobody put you in the corner Morango
Morango Morango morang dude I used to go
to Morango with $60 bro and lose it all
and come back
sad oh wow that's a long drive I used to
work there there used to be a guy there
a dealer I don't know if he's still
works there it was a middle eastern guy
his name was um I forgot his name
man we guy we used to play with his name
man his name was a that's what it was
he's still there Hassan he taught me how
to deal I forgot what his name
Hamed yeah so I just want to call let
you know you know I listen to your guys'
uh podcast and um to all of them and you
guys are doing good man thank you man
you're a blackjack dealer or what yeah I
met you a few times I met you at a
Raider game I was all drunk with a bunch
of people and I went to go see your
guys' show at the Ice House me and my
lady I met you a couple times you and
Rodrigo what's up how you been I think I
did see you in Morango then I was
passing
by I wasn't the one that took your money
hell no bro I lost a lot of money but I
lost my dad's Fortune there bro I could
have been an American
Greed was
unfortunate so what happened bro you
tell yourself to open an account for you
on the
side oh
[__] hey so who's the gu yesterday s
Karim bro from ministry right here to
the left of me yo yo say what's up I
lost some money at at the Morango too
man yeah I'm only in the daytime you
guys sound like you come at night so
yeah I come at night bro yeah 2 in the
morning from the pretty girls I haven't
seen no pretty girls there bro when I go
there bro it's the old beat up about the
dealers they take your money man the
only pretty girls I see bro are those
cockta wages the L that they were crying
for 2 hours and they went they went to
work and got a boob job on the side for
real man some of those girls L that they
used to be models for low rider and
48 they're putting themselves through
school man for real times bad hair
extensions man night school you want a
drink listen listen
mortia it's true dude most of them sound
like Lou
rolls oh [__] some cigarettes r
yeah and the the casino police look
crazy too
Mano the guy arested me one time but he
gave me 45 odds I was going to get out
so I got out all right people enough
with the casino
jokes thanks for calling bro hey no
problem thank you guys doing what you're
doing and uh I'll get at you guys soon
you guys have a good day likewise too
let's call that fo sneaky bro Mr sneaks
hey everybody I'm just want to say hello
to
everybody what's up
F yo what's up what's up Felipe what's
up man what's up what's up Ted Martinez
right no this is um Julian man from
belflower I know man I just F throwing
names out there bro what up Julian
what's up man Bower
bro how's frit strip
bar how's the strip bar Fritz rightz
it's Fritz I'm like bro somebody told me
man that Johnny Cash could look out of
the window of his tour bus and in two
exits know what city it
is you what you told me yeah I heard
that from Jerry that's funny man funny I
already took Rodrigo's story away I
already forgot sit right next to him
too I think I could do that cash man but
um best
concert was
uh
which one was it
dog that was in Oakland I saw Future
Islands at the fox damn just Google that
bam
bro we're all going for our phones over
here like oh yeah future Island how was
it dog it was bad man they dat K song to
me I got the set list it was pretty cool
my cousin jumped on stage
d a song to you bro I CAU a drum I
caught a drumstick was from
Popeyes what kind of music
play um like a s pop kind of um punk
kind of it's a mix of everything it's
bad man you should check them out I'm
I'm G look them up
bro they're pretty cool bro think you'll
like them and Oakland huh yeah in
Oakland but they're from Baltimore but
worst show man was the LA pod Fest like
about two weeks
ago this fool dog you repping with with
your T-shirt hu yeah bro I was there me
and my chick man the only reason I went
I got free tickets through
KCRW
kcw yeah you didn't have nothing to do
that weekend hot
dog this guy said honey we're going to
go watch
shows and then we're going to have tacos
no talking about he drag oh those tacos
though bro they look
good yeah went to the tacos on Brian
Venice there's some good pastor tacos
man
bran venis I been to a couple of tacos
trucks but they were good but they were
like an Echo Park by the back of
V Co man right man well than for calling
dog oh yeah thank you for representing
dog all right
fool what's up
fool what's up fol Mando in the house
what's up hey hey hey
K what's up fool who's this hey this is
uh this is Steve from Colorado what's up
Steve from Colorado what up a not much
just call to hit up funny Felipe what up
fool how you been ah hanging bro it's
been it's been tough this year but keep
putting one foot in front of the other
listening to uh funny Felipe every
Wednesday getting through the thing you
know how it is H yeah man we're here
with s for Ministry over here and Rod
hey what's up bud how's it going what up
man I was just in Colorado a couple
weeks ago we're at the high elevation
Festival we played oh nice I've never
even heard of that it was up in like a
veale or something like that no it was
right in uh Denver
Englewood [__] this fool mentioned Veil
bro Veil I went to Veil Colorado we did
the last coming tour over there oh my
God I was just uh cold there like a snow
Town huh oh big snow Town bunch of
they're
all there kees two little sticks going
down the hill careful
trees yes everybody's friendly there man
like if you're if you if you're running
out of something they'll give it to you
but they want you to leave right after
we're here to help each other out you
know immediately they want you to leave
Veo though get in and get out yeah man
ve um they they have Big Concert Hall
there a Big Concert Hall and um the
whole town is literally like snow
caps yep one after another nothing there
I think they filmed um that that's the
town where they supposedly filmed um and
I'm making it up right now The
Shining The
Shining I started was when I was
there oh this cool this we flew there
man really just f it to you make it
Felipe you know how to do it dog that's
what said hey Felipe you know what bu I
want to say I want to say thank you to
uh you and Rodrigo man you guys give us
this free content every week it's so
much fun to listen to your podcast man I
I I you know what I do for a living I I
I work for UPS and I load uh uh trailers
full of packages to be shipped around
you know like you used to do hell yeah
bro get that flow going hey was I lying
bro that you sneeze dirt
oh bro the the the the the black boogers
that you blow after being in this place
is ridiculous man particle dust
dog hell yeah bro and then and all they
give you hey bro you you give us a you
give me the funny fool like people will
be walking past my trailer and I'll be
laughing my ass off fool with my coll my
headphones on and I'll be laughing hard
at you and Rodrigo and and people just
look at my chair they like this fool
I'll be like what up
what's up fool hell yeah y so thanks for
what you're doing and next time you come
I know you you visited uh peblo but
that's a little bit down the road and I
wasn't able to make it so but next time
you're in Denver fol for sure hell yeah
bro next time I'm in Denver we're going
bro me and
Rodrigo yeah getting them Ducket you
guys are coming back or what hopefully
if they book me oh yeah I keep I keep
getting on the uh uh Comedy Store over
there to get tell Comedy Works bro yeah
Comedy Works there lown so yeah but keep
on doing Felipe dud it's cool to see
your rides fol you know you came from
rag to riches and you you did it
yourself bro also bro watch me on
Superstore next week October 13 NBC
Channel at 900 PM oh for sure you know
what my stone assh is gonna set it right
now so I don't set it bro all right bro
thanks s bab set up BR yeah man what can
Brown do for
you hi yeah man
this for all I I if you never been to B
it is [__] cold as [__] over there my
mom lied and my
dad that's a long job that she picked
the farthest
place what's up
fool what's up fool this in a steel meal
bro so hard to get into you guys man you
got in bro ouch what are you doing man
where you calling from yo this is Nathan
from Oxnard man yeah this I called you
up uh I just recently posted up last
weekend a picture of me with a thiso
t-shirt my buddy passed on the couch
yeah before we seen that [__] was funny
man I thought that was funny so I had to
send that to you yeah enjoyed the show
in Oar I wanted to talk to you about
that and [__] what happened man no it
was cool man I had a great time I walked
up to you said what's up fool and you're
like what's up mlo oh what's up fool
yeah I remember now little wife yeah and
I came with my buddy and his lady and
everything and yeah it's crazy though it
was a badass show how Levity Live I like
L live it's better than the other
place waiting so long for that place to
open hell yeah and then when your
tickets went on sale bottom as soon as
they came out
man what's your favorite concert you
ever been to oh dude I'm a DI meica fan
so I've been to two different Metallica
concerts and uh you're Metallica F yeah
yeah went to one recently I mean it
wasn't too bad one back to day both in
La sound like you're flying bro close
the window and nothing else matters he's
a pilot I'm at work right now I'm
walking I'm trying to hold on one
second where work at we're waiting for
you where do you work at air traffic
controller so
uh build Machines man go CNC machines
machines want to say I can't remember
him now he's backing up a for Clift
right R over dog
yeah he makes still
plates I was close bro the food steel
meal hey D can't wait for uh uh using
show to come out man I hope so too man
me too it's going to be tight we're
still looking for a
sister yeah I heard you're gonna do the
casting everything like that helling a
lot so man how how how loaded have you
been at a Metallica
concert last time I went was like cuz
I'm just 30 so last time I was like 22 I
wasn't too
loaded I'm pretty I'm pretty basic over
here hell yeah
basically I remember uh one one of the I
think it I don't know if it was krock
ween Rose or Lala paloa Metalica was
headlining and um yeah but no no no no
no but Metallica was headlining but the
Cure was going up before them damn so
dude everybody with there for Metallica
showed up too early man boys don't so
they yell
Metallica
Metallica and by the time Metallica went
up passed out bro I mean their friends
shooting fireworks out of their
ass sleep T cuz it was weird because
when the Cure went up they went up
before Metallica man and a lot a lot of
the mods were there dancing and I don't
know man The Cure should have went up
earlier yeah last year I went to I was
sitting up in the nose bleeds they
didn't have any money and uh there's a
13y old kid that kid down in the front
in the pit man I was all jealous
how do you know he's
13 James an pointed him
out how do you know who we are I know
man I'mma Point At You Next time bro
next time on the show
mlo yeah M and then when you when you
open the show you opened up with Sweet
Caroline I yelled it out loud and you're
like there's the only white boy
here than well so thanks for calling man
yeah man he next month
yes hell yeah dude
peace
hello hey what's up fool what's up F
who's this
man
East what's up dog from Florida huh fol
yeah man for Hurricane mat you hell yeah
dog I'm glad I finally got through 150
150 kind that time hell yeah dog you
were saying you wanted to get through
for sure hell yeah man what's his name
we're we hung out with them in Naples in
Naples chice oh he on the back at the
parking lot yeah yeah yeah chis yeah oh
what's up cool he showed up he showed up
with his wife they drove my home girl
yeah yeah we drove three hours just to
see you guys hell yeah chis showed up at
at some other show with a Asian guy a
Jewish guy a black guy he go make a joke
about
that yeah I'm sitting here just dabbing
waiting for this rain to stop so I can
finish putting on the shutters at my
house wow man we saw a picture of Adam
Murray and he was getting ready for the
the thing and some lady had bunch of
waters on her cart right and um and then
um Adam Murray said yeah I remember my
for Hurricane
scar no there are people fighting out
here and ARG lot for the gas pumps
fighting for water I swear to God
they're not going to go anywhere dude
nobody are they're driving away from the
from town or what no they're just
stacking up on gas for their generators
for their
cars
wow yeah
man [__] man let me tell you right now
man here in California nobody ha
earthquake stuff ready
man oh hey you never know when
earthquake going to hear that's the
first thing that's gone when you got the
munchies and bonds is
closed to the survival
P hey Rodrigo um I'm gonna hit you up
later I need to order a couple shirts
from you yeah man send the DM yeah
before they sell out you I want to have
them got to have them bro hell yeah
what's your favorite concert dude the
best concert you've been to I can't even
remember
crocus I can't I remember we were going
to a concert but I don't remember even
getting there
Dam [__] up I people like that they
get to the concert so [__] up they
never make it inside miss the event
totally I even so my dicket dog Fu that
that would happen at Ali Raider games a
lot of people would get so loaded the
Ali Rider games that they didn't even
get in cuz they're too drunk or they get
arrested it's pretty calm now though
hell yeah yeah I don't know about those
Raiders but you know got another Cowboy
oh you're a Cowboy fan I forgot bro yeah
shooting
star hey when are you guys coming back I
don't know when we're coming back to
Florida man I start getting my dates for
Florida and December so by December I'll
know all right defitely when you got
guys come I'mma take you guys on the
boat go fishing we're ready bro jet
skiing bro Anglers over here no jet ski
I'm I'm put you on like a four 500 PB
grouper hell yeah bro I don't know what
that is but yeah it's a big ass fish
that can
eat one damn all you got vegan fish out
there we could
catch I don't know about no vegan fish
we can catch some sponge and seaweed
Spong oh get you some would you would
you want to eat a
flounder
fler
episode guy all I'm G let you guys go so
other callers can get in thanks for
calling chis hell yeah dude hear
remember this fool bro started raining
on us yeah it did dude it's all human
yeah man it was fun spark a lot yeah man
hell yeah I hope you enjoyed your gift I
gave you that night hell yeah did man
thank you dog thank dog got to take care
of you do oh
yeah was Adam Murray with us yeah I
remember
him what's up
fool oh my gosh I tried to call earlier
and I got disconnected I think I was too
excited I want to talk to
s's right here waiting for you
yeah I like cried I was freaking out and
then I don't what happened my phone just
hung up and then I literally kind of
cried I'm sorry s yes where you calling
from I'm from Dallas I'm the girl that
drove to Houston when you um when you
played like a couple months ago Houston
we just played and I met you you you
were there by
yourself oh when I did a a DJ game yeah
yeah yeah and it was the girl that
brought you all those cookies and then I
don't know if you can I yeah yeah yeah
in at
numbers was it at numbers in Houston oh
my God what kind of cookie were
they tried and then I I saw you guys um
last weekend we drove to Houston again
but I couldn't uh we I couldn't find you
what at the
festival yeah wait so you're from Dallas
we were right yeah we drove all the way
from Dallas I had a sign that said I
love you s but I don't know excuse me
Father for I have sin wow well thank you
for the cookies people bring me cookies
cuz they know I like that crap no you
don't drink huh
no well then I tried to like I don't
know I got I got nervous and got a
little weird and I don't know the people
that you were with were like no you gota
like so I just I don't know I wanted to
talk to you but I wow well thank you I
appreciate it thank you for in butf I'm
such a big fan when are you when can
when are you gonna I want to see your
parties are so fun like I will drive
anywhere when are you playing next uh
it's kind of a big drive to Mexico we're
playing there in uh like a
week Mexico City I don't think I can go
to Mexico yeah I got kicked out of there
one
time yeah um yeah that's the next that's
the next gig um and then uh yeah it's
even further to drive to Australia cuz
that's where I'll be at in a few weeks
so well I can go to Australia currently
so maybe I'll try to catch you that yeah
oh you know where you should go no well
it's I'm going to be in min
Apolis I could maybe do that yeah I
think you might be able to do Min that's
not too far from Dallas right start
driving
now listen start driving I drive it
bring some cookies so yeah bring the
cookies too can I brush your hair too
absolutely I somebody needs to somebody
needs to yeah yeah Minneapolis I'll be
get
stuck what happens to mine straighten my
hair my hair's like yours dude oh my God
you brush my hair or get stuck you pull
it out or
something I can't even believe I'm
talking to you right now I'm like huge F
slap yourself believe it if you don't
I'm gonna have
to I want you to do the first spank
yourself over the radio so we can hear
it yeah let's hear
it I can't do that right now bummer
throw a cookie at somebody you're not a
you're not a you're not a real fan
you're not a real fan
no no that's awesome thank you for the
call we appreciate itk you yeah remember
me Becky I'm going to show up to one of
your shows yeah yeah I remember you cool
awesome bye byebye thank you she's going
to show up at a show or she's been to a
show she says she went to a show in h i
was in Houston I had I had a DJ Gig in
Houston like a couple months ago and I
guess she says she went to that
so yeah but yeah you know what a bunch
of people bring me cookies out yeah
yeah she got through though huh H yeah
dude special phone oh yeah hardore
iPhone dude yeah speed arthritis now on
her fingers dude
hello hello hello more
cookies cookie
hotline you reach the cookie podcast the
Cookie Monster Hi who's this Beverly
Beverly hi Beverly where you calling
from Phoenix Arizona oh yeah man mon so
basically I'm calling because I am new
to you guys's podcast and I found it on
s's Facebook
actually cool cool s's right here hi s
how are you good how are you who's this
Beverly from Phoenix Beverly oh I think
I know
Beverly yeah from Phoenix um I'm just
basically at work in my office and I on
a lunch break so I'm just kind of you
know hanging out sin with everybody's up
to but I was pretty excited to see sin
and I wanted to catch up with sin and
see how he was doing cool I'm doing
great thank you for uh calling in and
for checking out uh Felipe and Rodrigo
here yeah they're you know what they're
you know they had me dying here in my
office my boss walked by Ador walked by
and I'm like laughing and my
administrator walks and he's like what's
wrong with you and I'm going well I'm
watching these guys for Lee and dgo and
oh my goodness I'm just yeah I was like
oh my God awesome thank you you guys are
really you know you guys are really
awesome and is there a possible way you
guys may come to Phoenix on tour amiro
we'll be coming on to Phoenix we usually
go to The 10p impr Improv or on April or
May when is it again T 10p impr improv
April or May we don't have a date yet
you could check on filipes world.com
bring them
cookies no actually likes chocolate sin
is a big chocolate person yeah I mean
sin is like you know sin is like my
second favorite guitarist so I've been
following him in researching then I just
happen to know chocolate is his thing it
is I I remember Beverly you know do you
guys remember real quick uh Chappelle
Show uh do you guys remember the the
prince basketball yeah game okay you
remember when he talks about Mickey free
the guy that played he was friends with
Prince he was the other guy that they
thought was a chick
yeah okay he's a real good friend of
mine this guy Mickey free he was a
guitar player in shalomar back in the
70s that's a real that real that whole
thing really happened and she's she know
you know Mickey right Beverly yes yeah
so she's she knows this guy Mickey free
was a friend of mine and that's how she
knows me was through Mickey really so
the whole thing when they made pan
that's all true and real Mickey free
dude yeah very good that's awesome I
remember you B yes yeah so you know a
lot of I get the ultimate question on
Facebook they like yeah you know we all
know who your favorite guitarist is but
you have a second favorite guitarist and
I'm like you know of course I do you
know but he's on my Facebook too you
know what I mean and yeah but s's a
really awesome person but I mean guys
really s biggest thing is he like he
loves chocolate and I just want to say s
you're one of the best feed metal
guitars ever I mean from Ministry to
society one to resolving coffee all this
wow thank you bar I'm I'm impressed
thank you usually I hear just people
talking [__] about me it's nice to hear
somebody say something nice about me oh
yeah thank you no no no guys and I'm
really glad I got the chance to tune in
you know I'm always on s's page little
do but I'm always on your page I know
what's going on you know so this how
actually caught up with this whole whole
podcast but I love all you guys and you
guys are doing a great J than for thank
you very much Beverly thank you
and my best concert ever was I know this
is going to sound crazy but um I believe
is when Ministry was in wackin and they
were doing the whole live stream thing
do you remember that 10 of course you
did yeah I was
there yeah we streamed I was watching I
was watching that but that was a great
that was like one of my favorite
concerts but I'm still waiting for
Ministry to get to Phoenix hopefully
next year we'll be doing some us dates
but uh yeah thank you very much Beverly
we appreciate it thanks bever thank you
have a good one day you too hell yeah I
saw Diana Ross at the celebrity ball in
Phoenix the one that does the turning
the circle the Celebrity Theater the
Celebrity Theater yeah celebrity theater
and the show there was some lady
heckling her the when she would get
quiet Diana the kamacho family loves you
Mika the kamacho family loves you and I
swear to god dude at one moment I
thought D was going to say shut up [__]
I know the Mao family loves
you we want shout out to get shout ruing
it bro oh it's [__] horrible mucho
family loves you I would like [__]
shut up [__] we know
[__] what's up
fool what's up how they doing
hello what's up man oh man I haven't
talked to you guys in a minute how you
been who's this D King it's martinz
Randle oh what up fool the one that said
that the he was in parking lot and that
dude's a trump fan he was a Mexican dude
he's a disgrace oh yeah Mar how are you
bro what up dog I've been good I'm
[__] call on the Shelf you're coming
to Salt Lake the 27 hell yeah Mia
Rodrigo and Keith Manning oh dude yes me
there too making a shirt special shirt
I'm all like [__] I'm G get all dabed
out I'm G try to get all I'm going to be
the full laugh of two hearts hey bro you
know the last time I was there so chick
brought her newborn
bro oh my God and the witard almost
tripped over the baby oh that's the
second time that happened cuz they
brought a baby to Irvine yeah
remember oh okay oh yeah dude that's
tight though wow bad dude babies are
cool dude hell yeah bro we should go to
the we should go have some tiet potatoes
bro do they just added a new vegan donut
shop that I was going to tell you you
need to check out when we're going to
hot boox that place is dog he's on it
dog what's the name of it I don't know
the name of it they just opened up this
month that's why I was like oh wow is
that nice like he's coming down and
there there's some new vegan spots
opening up Sal Lake
City hell yeah um I've been [__] no I
I commented on one of your posts too
because I work at a dry cleaner every
time people come in I'm like oh yeah you
know pH comes out who like you know when
you hear me call you a fool this is the
fool who told me to call
people and they're always like oh okay
you know I wanted to tell you guys you
guys drive a personality I know a couple
people who listen to your podcast and
they act like you know they try to be
like oh this D or this fool it's like
you know it's it's you guys you guys try
you guys drive that onto people and I
noticed my bosses even noticed like wow
you call me
fool you used to have such a dry
personality you know I know man a couple
of Pastor say Amen
Yen a couple of Pastor don't say Amen no
they say
Yen the power of Christ compells you
yeah man you only are you only going to
be here for three days or how long are
you guys GNA be here well I don't know
what time we
land times your flight iary 27th like
the three days we get to the day of the
show right wait where Salt Lake Salt
Lake no you'll be there the night before
we're going to get to the the night
before the show
bro oh [__] what what's up we got C out
we got to [__] eat some [__] I'm down
bro let's go eat I know I know I know
Place bro that has Tibetan food but they
make the best potatoes bro they make to
potatoes with um that chili paste and
rice bro it tastes like the potatoes
taste like chorizo wow that sounds damn
that sounds fire it does bro they're
like I never thought that potatoes with
a side of white rice would taste good
but it does that's good you gotta make
him I have I have to tell you guys too
the last podcast was like the [__] in
this podcast what you guys had with Lis
yeah that dude it was like enchilada
casserole mixed in with what so full I
don't think I couldn't stop laughing the
whole [__] time you guys need to get
her on there more hell yeah bro that's
just the three of
us just the three of us month two of us
one month once a
month y I know you guys always say
I'm gonna have all kinds of DS when you
guys get here I hope you guys manag to
hit me up I want to guys you know blow
you guys up I would love to you know
talk to you guys a little bit hell yeah
bro keep me posted dog it's on hell yeah
yeah and I yeah I'll keep watch me on
Watch Me on NBC next week bro on 9 o'
Superstore I'm gonna be on the show
October 13th next
Thursday what what what can you tell me
right now that you're not gonna get in
trouble with what you're doing with
Justin abara
what oh no about the show yeah about the
show about your deal about if you what
could you tell him that you won't get in
trouble like any insight information
about the show that you don't that oh
nothing I don't know what do you want to
know I don't know everything what it
about the show the show is about three
brothers no three brothers and sisters
two two brothers and we have one sister
and she's gonna play like the like the
girl that that um that she wants to she
wants to be mayor of course of the of um
the city and she's an overachiever bro
and she's an overachiever bro she's like
the sister that went to college did
everything right hooked with hooked up
with a white dude hooked up with a white
dude you know it's going to be a
homeowner and um and Dustin bar he's
like the kid who has to stay home and
take care of grandma and do all that and
me I'm the guy who just came out of
being a loser bro and I'm trying to
change my
life but like the I'm not I'm not it's
like um me and my sister we fight
because um she's trying to be the mayor
of the city but I'm I'm already the
mayor bro just on
reputation knows you hell yeah bro I'm
like Kramer bro everybody likes me oh
man um that's tight and I mean I like I
barely read something about it on your
page that's why I had to ask a little
bit that's too F
funny want to go to all three shows
what show gonna be the best show Friday
your guys's first show the best show
gonna be
Thursday I know there's gonna be a time
because like I don't know about going up
here Waring people they don't get me I
think they're all gonna be good bro it's
gonna be
tight you like I said you're an amazing
comedian go too I'm excited to catch you
guys both here the last time we were
there um hell yeah thank you bro the
last time we were there we hooked up was
a couple bikers bro hooked us
up yeah
man I know you guys always crack jokes
on your podcast like I hate it when we
go somewhere and people give us the pen
like all right all right give it back
after a couple SNS I'm oh man these guys
don't know I'm G throw a
[__] H bro man we were hanging up with
Mike FS last
weekend oh I know I thought you it was
the Mike and what else who else there G
gang Gary Johnson andir Rodrigo bro
that's it yeah Owens
cancelled oh D he he canel story when
you guys get here hell yeah bro tell you
yeah
man all right UT stay stay tight all
right Martinez Rand put a
Mormon yeah yeah
man Rodrigo over here has a his lady on
his phone that's a new thing what he has
his girlfriend on his phone bro that
have
cats he went for the real [__] all
right
people this
mother all right people back to us
what's up F what's up
dog what's up F what's up fool who's
this Alex the large everybody has to
think about it first huh I know huh who
am I let me see they're getting
questioned by the cops huh get nervous
bro like I got to take out my ID get
Authority figur that's funny when when
when Latinos and black people and white
people who grew up in the hood you know
they grew up in a bad neighborhood
whenever you ask their name they always
take inventory of their lives first R
Warren light flashes Before Their Eyes
on if the cops are around yeah there's a
pause what up Alex the
large chilling man Chillin oh yeah bro
on my lunch break today man the the the
Jehovah Witness came to my house and I
don't want to be rude and just slam the
door like I did last time turn time I
actually like I said yeah yeah see just
leave leave that paper on my porch and
go they ask for my name bro I didn't
give him a real name it took a
while what's your name and I paused
Jesus it is so that's my name phelipe
Jesus
Jesus what was your favorite concert big
dog you ever been
to me
yes [__] that's easy that's easy to
short at a low rider uh car show damn
perfect huh
[__] H yeah bro best best nachos I ever
had they skipped on the jalapenos though
dog when I was 15 man that [__]
waso yeah man damn getting where you fit
in dog two shorts still had afro huh
shorty the pimp he was always bald
though for I remember I wed through two
short man at the airport he can we get a
picture nah man a I want to get that fo
in a strangle hold bro he was there with
no bodyguards either well I would have
just took a selfie dog and I run into
him three times already bro really
where's the other two another time I
coming out of a Dodger game in San Diego
and he was driving his car and I yelled
out t- Shir and that fo said what's up
and another time he was walking by and I
yell out two sh where's that app I
forgot do that app dude app's around
everywhere
doging I F hang out Inland no more
dog yeah I kind of very disappointed
about that bro a dude I hate I went home
and threw my cassettes away happened at
La hey before I forget uh I I finally
made that shake that you told me oh yeah
all good I put everything in it hell
yeah bro put everything in almond milk
ice almond butter spinach dates cinnamon
and I'm going be honest with you man
something happened that has never
happened before in my life I [__] and
I'm not going to blame it on you but uh
I [__] my pants like right before I got
home from work one day [__] my God you
finally got that old rubber band out of
there dog [__] I'm not going to
blame it on you I thought it going to be
like like change my life I got the nor
piece Prize or
something you finally got cleaned
out it came out smooth wow she
luckily I was on my way home luckily I
was on my way home I stopped at 7-Eleven
real quick and I was like what the [__]
is that I thought my ass sweat you know
on the way home from work like what the
[__] is
that while I was sitting down you what
happy bro you're turning into popey do I
F I F while I was sitting down and I was
like what the [__] is that it was a
shitty day and um hey bro it was it was
black got it was black right
hell no that [__] looked like almond
butter it looked just like almond butter
did you ever to the doctor did you did
you eat like did you eat healthy the
whole day and that's what it happened
yeah that's all I drank the whole day
that's what happens bro um when you
start eating like healthy like you start
stay stay away from that that fried food
for a while your body in a way cleans
itself out and then you poop
black oh those toxins have been in there
forever
huh black them I try to I triy to blame
it on my sister's
dog you dog food
now [__] Purina over here
dog wow man thanks for sharing it was
horrible dude it was horrible and I
waited cuz I was already at home I said
[__] it I probably just you know a
little bit came out hell no man I went
to the bathroom I was like what the [__]
I was embarrassed dude hey bro to talk
about hey bro where did you hide the
underwear he put it on the dog that's
why you blame the dog thre that [__]
away you not I said enough
I on my sister's
dog you still drinking the shakes though
dude n [__]
that need a diaper for that
[__] this drink water all day either got
to get used to it dog you got to have
one every day bro went for lunch
what's in the shake what is it what you
tell him to have no it's just almond
milk Alm one tell them
bro okay seven ice cubes seven dates
almond butter almond milk cinnamon and
uh SP
banana the banana bro what you forgot
the banana oh and a banana yeah he
for you know what I did I had Taco Bell
for
lunch oh it's a Taco Bell Taco Bell for
L
too
stay away from the inito
dog they got a [__] Fredo burrito
dude oh that's what it was dog damn I
might have that after to have that today
you know a lot of people like you're
still there right you're listening a lot
of people talk a lot of a lot of
Mexicans well I won't say a lot of
Mexican but the ones that are they're
think they're hardcore Mexicans they
hate on Taco Bell bro but you you go to
you go say that you go to Taco Bell they
love it dude Mexico's mexic in Mexico
love it dude [__]
no Taco Bell Taco Bell I can't stand I
can't stand [__] Chipotle [__] that
[__] I don't like Chipotle either but I
got food poisoning
twice one DC I went back the next year
and I got food poison again we ate in
Atlanta that one
time it just cold though that's the only
thing evolved enough you're not evolved
enough to eat it I love bean burritos
bro and Taco Bell I seven of them in a
row I won't bro I'll try I three of them
yeah it'd be cool with three I'm down
what's up fool what's your favorite
concert
bro
again hell yeah bro we're doing a
podcast with this guy thanks for calling
bro thanks for sharing the Nala
story I had to throw them away and
they're my favorite
boxers just watch you remember of that
movie I just saw human human switchblade
or army man swis I just saw a movie
called Swiss army man and it's a guy
that the whole time he's um he has he's
hanging over a dead guy like like we can
at Bernie and he's carrying him
everywhere and he's he's stranded on an
island he's stranded on an island and he
puts up one of those quirks in his butt
for he could stop
farting does it work yeah what the [__]
but then he [__] lets it go bro and
lets a real fire and he flies into
space this called watch this movie
annihilated bro get annihilated and
watch a movie called
um Swiss army man where where did you
watch this guy Paul Dano and a kid from
um rad flick R where on what on uh
Netflix Netflix on Netflix let me check
it out
dog that was come theater bro Swiss army
man bro wow and then that F has a the
guy has a strong you know how when
you're dead de you got rig Mor and he a
[__] um hard ass hand that f using
that food to chop stuff
bro that [__] arm is on Petri he uses
that fool's arm to chop stuff and then
later on the dead the dead fool the the
dead Fool's farting he takes that fool
to the ocean and he using the F of jet
ski dog the [__] up dog swis army man
bro guys F I don't know dog if Paul Doo
and that kid from Harry Potter oh really
really dude bad ass dog oh shut up dude
but the ending throws you off bro the
whole movie was weird the whole movie
was weird bro cuz that fool's talking to
him oh my God yeah bro when that fool
was farting that fool uses that fool to
light fires
improvising but the whole time that F's
dead they should be banned they should
be they should be everybody involved
should be banned for making
movies think about it bro a lot of
people go a a lot of people have
meetings with movie Executives they
picturing movies and this F and swiss
army man and shark NATO got through dude
I would love to be in the fire on on the
wall in that meeting speaking of poly
Shore bro I went to his page again this
week and he [__] chasing that guy for
more Chinese soup um his Snapchat dude
that Snapchat is bizarre going Chinese
soup he open the guy's door and goes
Chinese soup Chinese soup imagine short
shut up at your house saying Chinese
soup Chinese soup and that guy is making
Chinese soup for him bro probably been
like that since he was a little kid dog
probably huh yeah fool he always had
that snap from that little restaurant in
Silver Lake dude he goes to the guy's
house and he [__] he's making chines
soup we need to start annoying that
fool we should H hey buddy p short
Snapchat talking to this drunk ass
Mexican fool with no teeth
bro what was he telling
I don't know Chinese suit but I don't
know thanks for calling Nas Alex peace
out brother that fool [__] himself
dog baby me oh
D play on sister dog we got s Karin here
bro Rodrigo to from the what so F and
yeah man Lisa in the back we got s lady
right here from the UK GNA bake some
cookies before she gets on the way home
what's up fool who's uh
who's another guest quiet guy what's up
little
twink listener what's up last
caller hey what's going on Felipe I'm
glad I got through man all the way from
Detroit no way I'm from Vegas man Vegas
what up dog from
what this hey this is your ugly friend
Carlos cool what's up dog what's up bro
I didn't recognize you bro you I thought
you going to buy an Apple to let us
know no I I didn't get a piece of it
because that [__] was rotten you know my
didn't kick in this [__] what
up for you here with SC Karin from
Ministry hey you got me on hold hello
hello hey what up no we have you right
here what's happening yeah you're live
bro you're on YouTube people are
listening yeah hon to top it up with
that long haired ugly guy Felipe man
what's
up all the way from Las Vegas blackjack
dealer sinin
City n I'm a dealer but now I don't deal
Blackjack you feel me oh sh what your
deal bro oxy cardan nickel
bags hey I wanted to ask you guys a
question bro yeah
man man how do I make it in the comedy
world because you know I'm a funny ass
wet back but I got like a [__]
but be the first one dog bro what you
got to do bro first of all go to a bar a
restaurant where they know you already
where they know you already and you go
there a lot and you tell that guy that
you want to do a comedy show and you get
the five comedians that you can find
that you can pay $50 to put up a nice
comedy show and you host that [__] and
in between acts you make these
[__] laugh there you go dog
hell
yeah but it has to be
like yeah bro but it has to be a place
where you're showcasing other five
people that are funnier than you and you
could just showcase yourself in between
for little bits at a time bro because
you you you don't want them to see you
do a whole set cuz then they'll judge
you on that whole set well this guy
[__] sucks you got to give a little
bit of time bro you got aost show I was
looking you up on uh YouTube and [__]
man you what happened to you bro to be a
real goodl looking young man bro I know
bro drugs cocaine and bad
nights [__] I better cut it down you got
to cut it down bro cuz those when I did
those photos I was
18 those [__] boot you know hell yeah
bro every once in a while you got to go
to a
meeting you gotta go to
that hell yeah bro so so what what you
do in Vegas besides drug
dealing I cook and [__] I cook for a lot
of these [__] Bal out here oh like in
high place so like I get like most of
the I don't know just a bunch of lawyers
and [__] but [__] those we're here
talking about you man um what was that
what's up what was the best concert you
ever been
to yeah the last concert I went to was
your mom's n that [__] was pretty cool
bro
oh bro you're not going to make it the
comedian bro you're bombing you're
bombing hard dog if that's your best
joke bro you [__] Normandy over here
dog send the
Drone my girl she calling me a [__]
because I've been sitting here trying to
call you guys all the time she like you
[__] she's funnier
dog put her on yeah where she
at B some
cookies over with her [__] guc now
and I'm out here trying to Redial you
[__] got a
light all right next caller somebody
saved this for where's a hook give girl
a
hook what's up
fool all right hey that guy suck wow
didn't get his name or
nothing ugly ass friend from Vegas
Jesus oh my God he had those long pause
jokes oh yeah he was thinking about him
dog I know man I think he was trying to
act tough bro because lady was right
there you gave him the whole like
formula how to start and he didn't even
like think about or nothing he like want
him that worth my time bro yeah man you
get you trying to give people advice but
they don't listen to you bro they get
stuck living in places like Juan Garcia
bro that already oh my God D CH boy in
that house bro episode one yeah check
them out man send him a message give
give our listener the dates where you're
going to be at yeah um Ministry we're
playing Mexico um not fest with uh I
don't know slip knot and Deon on that
showon Offspring uh October 16th in Toca
Mexico and then I go to I'm going to be
in Australia
October TW uh 20th to the 31st doing DJ
shows and and some guitar clinics out
there and then Minneapolis I have a DJ
show uh at Ground Zero November 5th I
believe and then that's it we're just
working on a new ministry record and a
new revolting Cox record right now till
the end of the year [__] yeah dude yeah
what's up full Ono improv again October
7th through the 9th sold out Arlington
Virginia DC area October 14 and 15 at
Arlington Draft House San Diego
California October 21st one night only
humre by the break bring your paddle boo
Salt Lake City Utah at Wise Guys Comedy
Club hanging out with that food just
called us everything you want to know
philppe
world.com
tour also keep watching me on everything
you want everything you want let even
make sense think comedy also man write a
review do something what's up fool rrio
yeah man hit me up for some me man
t-shirt and we're going to be starting a
show at Flappers on Monday night once a
month on November 21st it'll be the
first show you guys keep shining peace
out thank you for being on this in you
get C let them know